[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY SEHN: Hi, Diane.
DIANE GREENE: You know,
we'll all sit down.
But I don't know if all of you
need to stand up and sit down
for a second.
It's kind of cold in here.
And give you all a-- you know,
what is it, the seventh inning
break or something?
TIMOTHY SEHN: This is not LA.
CHRIS O'NEILL: Is this
because we're Canadian, Diane?
DIANE GREENE: OK.
All right, we can sit.
So yeah, I'm really-- you
know, what fun to have
Chris, CEO of Evernote, and
Tim, head of-- VP of engineering
at Snap.
And you guys do have
a bit in common.
Snap has 100 million
active users, at least,
according to your website.
TIMOTHY SEHN: I think the
last published number was 150,
but we'll see.
DIANE GREENE: We
think maybe more.
And then you have your very
popular application with--
or service with-- 200 million.
And I guess you are both, just
like our previous speaker,
Canucks.
CHRIS O'NEILL: Yes.
TIMOTHY SEHN: Yes.
DIANE GREENE: Yes
CHRIS O'NEILL: We are.
Diane, we'll try to
keep the gloves on,
and we'll keep the hockey
references to a minimum.
DIANE GREENE: OK.
CHRIS O'NEILL: But you have
to forgive us if we disappear.
So Canada is playing in
the World Cup of Hockey
later tonight.
And--
DIANE GREENE: Oh, OK.
CHRIS O'NEILL: Yeah,
right, against Europe.
And if we don't watch it, I
think the Canadian government
might revoke our passports.
DIANE GREENE: OK.
So you two have taken
different paths to the cloud.
Evernote was on-prem.
You're just starting
to move to the cloud.
CHRIS O'NEILL: Yeah.
DIANE GREENE: When you
arrived at Snapchat,
it was running on
Google App Engine.
TIMOTHY SEHN: Absolutely.
DIANE GREENE: And you've
built systems both on premise
and in the cloud.
What have you
found about working
in the cloud that's different?
Is it better?
Is it worse?
TIMOTHY SEHN: Sure.
To answer the last
question first,
I think it's
unquestionably better.
I like to tell a story about
when I arrived at Snapchat.
So I'm employee 18.
When I started there, my
engineering team was 10.
The most experienced
engineer on the team
had three years of
engineering experience.
The application was doing--
DIANE GREENE: Fresh thinking.
TIMOTHY SEHN: Yeah, yeah,
fresh thinking, yeah.
So the application was doing
between 200,000 and 300,000
queries per second
to the back end.
Not a single one of those
people carried a pager.
So they just assumed
it would work.
And we were having 5%
week over week growth.
And Google was chugging
along in the background.
Now, I'm not-- I'm not going to
pretend there weren't problems.
Once I got there, I spent a
year working with Google to kind
of optimize and get better.
But I was certainly
not-- the application
wasn't down all the time.
You think back to the early
days of Twitter's hyper-growth,
and everyone would
joke about fail whales.
We had none of those.
And so I apologize to anyone
from Twitter in the audience
If there is anyone.
DIANE GREENE: Yeah.
You told me, I think,
when I met you in January,
that you had 16 sysops people.
TIMOTHY SEHN: So
I had 10 people,
and I operated the
servers myself.
DIANE GREENE: Oh, you were
the only sysops person.
TIMOTHY SEHN: Yeah, I would page
myself whenever it went down.
And then I would cut
a ticket to Google,
and we'd work
together to fix it.
My friend and colleague from
Amazon, Aaron, joined me.
And then we would do it
together, the two of us,
until about April or May.
So for about the first eight
months I was at Snapchat,
I was the lone operator
and VP of engineering.
DIANE GREENE: Yeah,
still laughing.
Chris, you actually
came from Google.
I know you value our technology.
You value our innovation.
What is the technical
innovation that you're
looking for from Google?
CHRIS O'NEILL: Yeah, so
I've been at Evernote just
over a year.
And in the first
observation was,
we were trying to
do too many things.
And in this world, I don't
care what scale you're at,
you have to do a few things
and do them world class.
Like, we operate in every
country in the world.
So we really just did a
hard assessment of, like,
what things are we going
to really double down on
and what things are we not.
And operating a physical
data center just
was clearly not something we
wanted to differentiate around.
So once we'd made
that decision, we
asked ourselves a couple
questions, maybe three.
We said, OK, what's the
next three to five years
hold in terms of a
computing platform?
Who's the best in
the world at that?
And then, three, and
perhaps most importantly,
what are the
capabilities that we
need to really,
really meaningfully
differentiate and really
deliver value for our users?
The first two were
relatively straightforward.
AI and machine learning are
the next computing platform,
there's no question
in our minds.
And I'm a little
biased, perhaps,
from spending some
time at Google.
But Google clearly is
the leader in terms of AI
and machine learning at scale.
The third question was
about, what capabilities
do we need to marry
with the user's data
that they trust with us, right?
We have 5 billion notes and
5 billion more attachments.
This is people's very private
narrative of their life.
So how do we combine
that information with ML,
essentially, to unlock
some real user experiences?
And we like to say our
mission is to unlock
the potential of ideas.
So really, that's about
removing all friction.
So step one, for us, was voice,
a very practical implication.
I think we've hit a tipping
point when it comes to voice.
And Google has disclosed, 20%
of searches come through voice.
So we really want
to capture ideas
at the speed at which
people come up with them.
So voice is one big bet for us.
And we're really excited
about the NLP progress
that you guys have made.
So we think that's one
logical intersection.
And then, once people put
information of these ideas
into Evernote, it's
a very manual process
for organizing today.
And we think that the power of
what we saw just a little bit
about that powers Google
Photos, for example,
would really help
users, as I say,
organize without
really organizing.
It's like getting a six-pack
without going to the gym.
We can combine that
technology to help
people organize their content.
And then last but not least
is search or retrieval.
We really want to help people
surface the information
that they put in Evernote
at just the right time.
So when we thought
about, who's the leader,
and who could help
us with capabilities,
it was kind of a
no-brainer in the end.
And you, frankly,
were an intangible,
because you're committed to win.
And it was clear.
When we actually did look at
the intangible decision factors,
it was not even close in terms
of your ability and your desire
to win in this game,
even though you're
coming from a slight
disadvantage in terms
of when you started.
DIANE GREENE: Yeah,
you're both talking
about something kind
of interesting, which
is that for a longest time,
when you built a company,
you had to build absolutely
everything yourself.
CHRIS O'NEILL: We
didn't have a choice.
10 years ago,
there was no cloud.
There was no AWS.
DIANE GREENE: Right.
So now, all of a
sudden, you're going,
wait a minute, we don't have
to build everything ourselves.
And then, look at all the things
you want to take advantage of.
And these Stanford undergrads,
didn't even occur to them
to build everything themselves.
TIMOTHY SEHN: They
took the passive path
of least resistance.
DIANE GREENE: Yeah.
TIMOTHY SEHN: Frankly, for
me, it's about focus, right?
And I think that's what
he's talking about.
When you don't have to
worry about infrastructure,
and you don't have
to worry about,
is that rack going to land on
the front doors of your data
center so your network
engineer can cable it up,
and you can focus on
innovating on product,
you end up with just spending
more of your own cycles
and your team's cycles on
innovation, which is, I think,
where you end up
winning in the end.
CHRIS O'NEILL: They're winning
because of speed, I think.
And it's not just because
of selfies and photos.
It's actually because
you guys are really
innovating with product, right?
If you really ask
yourself who's pushing out
product at the highest quality
in that game, it's Snap.
TIMOTHY SEHN: And
we're proud of that.
And we owe a lot of
that to Google Cloud,
honestly, and have for
the last three years.
We would not be
able to do what we
have been able to do
without Google Cloud.
DIANE GREENE: And our
site reliability engineers
love you guys.
TIMOTHY SEHN: It's a love-hate
relationship, I think.
DIANE GREENE: They
pay attention, right?
TIMOTHY SEHN: Yeah, they
absolutely pay attention.
DIANE GREENE: So if you were to
look back, Tim, with all that
experience, and you
were your younger self,
is there any advice, if you
were just moving to the cloud
or doing things differently?
TIMOTHY SEHN: One of the
things I've really learned
is, managed services
make a big difference.
And depending on how
much state is preserved
dictates my desire for how
managed I want them to be.
So for a service where I
want large amounts of data
to live forever, I prefer that
to be as managed as I can.
And as I move up through
the caching layer
and into the serving layer,
I'm willing to tolerate
less and less managed--
or less or less
management-- of the services,
because it becomes easier,
as an engineer, to do that.
And so I would reinforce that to
my younger self and to others.
I think it's tempting,
as an engineer,
to want to control
your own destiny,
and take matters
into your own hands,
and know exactly how your
replication is working.
And it takes a
little bit of courage
to let that go, and give
that to someone else,
and just trust that
the data storage
provider or the front
end service provider
will be able to take
care of that for you
and take care of it better than
you possibly do it yourself.
And so just lean into that.
Again, this option wasn't
available 10 years ago.
You had to do it all yourself.
And so it exists now.
And the companies
that are going to be
able to move fast, and
execute, and win, I think,
are going to be the
companies that take
advantage of that advantage.
DIANE GREENE: And who
would have thought
that a camera company like Snap
would need this infrastructure?
I was hoping you would
wear some spectacles today.
TIMOTHY SEHN: It's
not unveiled yet.
So stay tuned next few weeks.
CHRIS O'NEILL: I think
if you frisked him,
you could maybe
find a pair, Diane.
DIANE GREENE: And
what about Evernote?
What's next for Evernote
over the next few years?
CHRIS O'NEILL: So it's
been a great year.
We've really invested in a bunch
of different areas, primarily
the team.
So I fundamentally
believe the team
you build is the company you
build, and the best team wins.
DIANE GREENE: Yeah,
you've made huge progress
in the last year, yeah.
CHRIS O'NEILL: Yeah,
so it's been great.
And we've also
invested significantly
in the technical
platform, right?
And GCP's a big part
of that, of course.
But there are many other things
under the hood that we've done.
And we're just so thrilled
to start unleashing,
on a regular cadence, stuff
that people will start to see.
I use the metaphor of
an iceberg sometimes.
A lot of what we've been doing
has been below the water.
So whether it's our search
technology, our editing,
or our sync technology,
these are all new things.
So people are going to start to
see those things in the coming
weeks.
And our users are really
excited in the early tests.
I think, more strategically,
if we look out a couple more
years, we've been a great
single player product.
And we really find-- and
there's appetite for us
to help impact teams.
So nothing great in the
world happens without teams.
And you saw a great
announcement from you guys.
We believe in that future too.
So how do we make
that migration--
it Is a fifth of
our business today--
without actually investing
very heavily in that?
So you can expect us to do that.
And I think that's another part
of the decision factor for us
too, was, when you try to
go win in the workplace,
the stakes are higher.
The stakes are higher
in terms of security,
in terms of compliance,
and all these other things.
And a lot of those things will
come as an added bonus for us.
So we don't have to, again,
think about all those features.
You guys can help us with that.
But we really want to
win in the workplace
and really help make teams 30%--
DIANE GREENE: We totally
want to help you.
We want to work
with you with apps.
I do think Tim cares about
privacy and security.
TIMOTHY SEHN: Absolutely.
DIANE GREENE: But
yes, absolutely, we'll
all-- the stakes,
the access controls
get more complicated in the
enterprise, that's for sure.
CHRIS O'NEILL: They do.
DIANE GREENE: Thanks, Tim.
Thanks, Chris.
Thank you very much.
CHRIS O'NEILL: Thank you, Diane.
TIMOTHY SEHN: Thank you, Diane.
Appreciate it.
Bye.
DIANE GREENE: OK.
[APPLAUSE]